[Music]
uniformly silent united in grief
Lester's players traveled to Veatch icy
Wattana propers native Thailand for his
funeral this week now it was the turn of
his adopted home to say goodbye earlier
fans had packed into the city's Jubilee
square the last time such numbers
gathered here was to celebrate the club
defying those odds to win the Premier
League title in 2016 famous faces joined
them including Lester's World Cup hero
Harry McGuire
but this tribute was driven by the fans
the amount of people that have come
today with one family it's not about
football colors and football shirts
today it's just one family my son Benny
got the most amazing childhood you know
watching he made the city like
supporting Kareem we just want to show
our appreciation of such a bullying
chairman I mean we were we were so
thankful
despite being rain drenched thousands
continued sky finally brightening as
they approached the King Power Stadium
memories of the horrific helicopter
crash which claimed five lives here two
weeks ago were not far away Peter
Schmeichel son Casper the team's
goalkeeper had attempted to save them
from the burning wreckage it's so sad to
lose someone who was that good for
everyone here
and Lester one of the city of the club
but I think in football in general and
uh you know having a son playing for the
club being so close to what happiness
has made it a little bit you know more
difficult in the last to lose but I have
to say coming over there it's just this
just really hit me there it's testament
to the fans
that when the club puts out to play
earlier this week to move the floral
tributes behind me from the stadium to
this car park 300 yards away too many
volunteers showed up but with it the
club have announced that a permanent
statue of Beach I see which are not
proper will be erected outside the
stadium but to recognize what he's done
for us it really has to be a monumental
statue football was relegated to a
footnote as teams from around the world
were bound by respects for the most
popular of owners the message was loud
and clear gone but not forgotten Martha
Kellner Sky News Lester